Frederick Krueger, later known as Fred, or most commonly Freddy, was born
in the early 1940s as the son of a nun named Amanda Krueger.
She was part of a religious order that ran an asylum known as Westin Hills
and did volunteer work there from time to time.
When Amanda was young, she was accidentally locked in award for the
criminally insane over the holidays and the inmates kept her hidden for days.
When she was found, she was barely alive and is now pregnant with a child,
–[Dr. Gordon] Freddy…
–[Amanda] The bastard son of a hundred maniacs.
While we don't know who the true biological father is, it was probably this guy,
just based on their similar appearance.  According to Alice Johnson's research on Freddy,
Amanda gave birth at that very same asylum.
I imagine she delivered the baby here as opposed to a normal hospital out of shame,
since nuns are supposed to be celibate.
She was panicked throughout the entire childbirth and the baby was breached,
meaning that he was going to come out feet first instead of headfirst.
There's probably some symbolism surrounding the fact that Freddy was born
upside down, with the mother being a nun and an upside down cross being
associated with the devil.
Because through his disastrous life experiences and eventual demonic intervention,
Freddy would indeed become the antithesis to God.
To learn about Freddy's childhood, how he became the demon of dreams,
The timeline I pieced together using bits of information throughout the franchise,
how he represents various scientific sleep phenomena and what the
future now holds for Freddy Krueger, stick around to the end of this video.
This video is sponsored by Audible.
♪ Metal Music ♪
-[Teacher] Welcome! To Freddy 101.
No, please shut up. Just please shut up.
But welcome to Horror History.
Can you believe I'm finally doing Freddy?
-[Announcer] Frederick, Freddy?
And that's actually a good clip for me to introduce this character because like
Major League Baseball these days, the rules are constantly changing in the Elm Street Franchise.
Freddy debuted as a dangerous dream spirit in the original,
A Nightmare on Elm Street, but by the second one, they had
already changed the rules, making him possess people in the real world to do
his biding.
And throughout the rest of the franchise, the rules keep changing.
Obviously, the best version of Freddy would just be to disregard everything
after the first one.
But that's not why you watch Horror History, is it? I'm going to try to make
sense of his entire timeline, but when it comes to the rules, there are
obviously going to be inconsistencies and I obviously am going to ridicule them.
I think what makes Freddy special for a lot of people is that he was
always played by the classically trained actor Robert Englund.
But that almost wasn't the case.
In 1985, during the production of A Nightmare on Elm Street 2: Freddy's Revenge,
New Line Cinema wanted to save money by just putting some nobody in a
rubber mask out there, which would have been funny, but also very bad and
the studio realized that and Englund got his check and probably a huge apology.
You can still see the masked version of Freddy right here, but in
this shot you can't really tell.
But you can try to impress your friends with that knowledge.
No one will care.
Hopefully they'll tell you to get a grip on your life.
Of course, there is no Freddy Krueger without his iconic finger blade glove.
According to director Wes Craven, this was inspired by his pet cat who
destroyed his couch with his claws, making him ponder his primal human fears
of being clawed to death by a saber toothed tiger in nature.
I guess he was still not over it twelve years later when he had
Billy Loomis go town on that couch in Scream.
But to fully understand the bastard cat of 100 plus dollars of ruined furniture,
we've got to take it back to his childhood and how he learned to
never show mercy on the kids.
♪ Synth Music ♪
Freddy was put up for adoption from a young age, and if I had to guess, it
was basically right away given Amanda's shame about having a child.
This didn't stop his classmates from learning
who he was and bullying him for it, chanting his nickname
Son of a Hundred Maniacs.
By the mid to late 1940s, he had already developed the murderous tendencies
that would carry over into his adulthood.
At one point, he can be seen smashing the class hamster with a mallet.
It seems even then, he'd taken a liking to wearing red and green stripes.
Fred's adoptive father is later found to be extremely abusive, so it's
likely that the abuse at home and at school is what led Freddy to becoming
abusive himself.
There's clinical research to back this.
The rate of abuse among individuals with a history of abuse is approximately
six times higher.
By his teenage years, Freddy learned to embrace the pain, going so far as to
slice himself with a razor while laughing just for entertainment.
By this point, taking the belts from his adopted father was nothing to him,
and he mockingly thanks him for the lashes.
-[Freddy] You want to know the secret of pain? If you just stop feeling it, you can start using it.
Is there any basis in reality for this? I think this is obviously an exaggerated version of a real concept,
and that concept is masochism, or the tendency to derive pleasure from one's
own pain or humiliation.
And masochism is often associated with bedroom activities.
We can only theorize as to why people develop this... condition.
There are a number of theories out there which I have read about for the
video, guys.
For the video.
One of which is linked to trauma.
The idea is that the victim of the trauma, in this case Freddy, is finding a
way to take control of this pain that was previously out of his control as a
coping mechanism.
It's basically the same idea as when someone says, you can't fire me, I quit.
-[Homer] You can't put me on hold, I'll put you on hold.
I think it's an interesting thing to keep in mind as we continue forward in
his story, because while it's never explicitly said outright, there are some
clues that there may be a carnal side to his slashings in Springwood.
But despite all of his issues, or maybe because of them, he manages to find
a wife named Loretta, and together they have a daughter, Katherine Krueger,
who was born in 1958.
And I know this because we're told that Katherine was taken away from him in 1966.
And her adoption papers state that she was adopted at eight years old.
The family lived together on Elm Street.
It was at some point during Katherine's life that Fred began kidnapping and
killing children in town, earning himself a new nickname the Springwood Killer.
Yeah, keep working on that one Springwood Gazette headline writers.
Freddy also crafted his own glove
using a blowtorch and some welding tools in his basement.
For each victim he took, he documented the moment in a scrapbook, as well as
an array of souvenirs that he kept in his basement workshop.
One day, Katherine moseyed into the basement where her father kept newspaper
clippings, photos, and other evidence of his crime.
It seems early on, he had an array of prototype gloves in addition to the
finger blade glove that we all know and love.
Like one with shorter knives seemingly taped to his fingertips, one with
nails affixed to his knuckles, and one with shorter, curved claws that looks
to be made of copper.
While Katherine is browsing through all of this, Freddy is up in the
backyard shaking and beating Loretta for discovering his secret collection.
He would indeed take Loretta's life over this, but he covered it up well
enough to make police think that she had just gone missing.
Mrs. Krueger, wife of Fred Krueger, just disappeared without a trace,
according to Detective Smith of the Springwood Police Department.
I mean, did they not check his basement? Something tells me this
Detective Smith is maybe not Springwood's brightest.
Freddy did find out that his daughter also stumbled across the room, but he
seems satisfied with letting her live and just threatening her not to tell anyone.
This would eventually come back to bite him in the nose,
but not for many more years.
Katherine was relocated to the orphanage in 1966, but Freddy would go on
terrorizing the town for a couple of years, and the body count would
continue to pile higher.
Then there was his job.
-[Jesse] Wow. What is this place?
-[Lisa] Fred Krueger worked here.
-[Lisa] It's an old power plant.
This is how Freddy managed to evade police as long as he did.
I'm guessing, after the scare with Loretta,
Freddy decided it was too risky to continue working out of his home
and instead took the kidnapped kids to the boiler room at this power plant.
It's estimated that he took 20 to 30 kids.
-[Marge] It drove us crazy when we didn't know who it was.
I don't know, maybe the weird guy whose wife disappeared and whose daughter
was confiscated by the States? Anyway.
It took a couple of years, but police finally had that big brain moment and
arrested Frederick Krueger in 1968.
I know this because this newspaper in the Dream Child announces the death of
Freddy's mother and says he was recently arrested in connection with the
Springwood child murders.
And Amanda Krueger's grave says that she died in 1968.
Freddy was put on trial, but in the end, someone didn't sign the search
warrant in the right place and Krueger was set free just like that.
The public was furious with headlines reading
Child Molester Acquitted; Citizens Outraged.
And this is actually the only place where Freddy is directly accused of
being more than just a child killer.
But there are more covert clues which I will go over as we go along.
I'd imagine that he was suspected of both but the prosecution just wanted to
focus on the murder charges because that was their strongest case.
In real life, Freddy actually was supposed to be a molester in an early version of
the script for the first movie.
But they dropped that part around 1982 or 1983 when some high profile cases
involving a daycare started making news cycles and producers didn't want it
to look like they were exploiting that.
If you watch my channel, you know that this isn't the only time that
director Wes Craven was censored due to current events.
See my video on Scream 3.
Anyway, when the law failed to take down Krueger the parents of Elm Street
decided to take things into their own hands.
-[Marge] We found him in an old abandoned boiler room where he used to take his kids,
-[Marge]took gasoline, poured it all around the place and made a trail of it out the door.
After that, all they had to do was toss a Molotov cocktail through the
window and watch the fireworks.
Yet, by some divine prank, Freddy had been chosen by a higher power.
Maybe they saw potential in him because of his ability to ignore pain.
Or maybe it was merely his infamy and notoriety in Springwood that made him
an ideal candidate.
But in his final moments, Freddy is approached by three dream demons who
offer him the opportunity to become eternal.
-[Dream Demon] Freddy, we know what you want.
-[Freddy] I want it all.
-[Dream Demon] Of course you do. Now open up and you shall be, forever!
Not much is known about the dream demons but they seem to go back to ancient
Greek times suggesting that Freddy's new role as a dream spirit could almost
be like a second coming of Epialos the Greek demon of nightmares.
The word Epialos means feverish, chill or daemon who assaults sleepers.
The dream demons themselves are depicted outside of the Temple of Morpheus.
Morpheus being the Greek god of dreams and nightmares.
-[Doc] These are ancient dream demons.
-[Doc] Supposedly, they roam the dreams of the living till they find the most evil,
-[Doc] twisted human imaginable.
-[Doc] Then they give them the power to cross the line and turn our nightmares into reality.
In any event, there's a lot of controversy regarding Krueger's death,
and each headline seemed to tell a different story.
Some say he died in the fire, others suggest suicide.
While some detail a vigilante style killing.
The parents hid his remains at Penny Bros. Auto Salvage
Somewhere that they knew nobody would find his bones because
nobody ever salvages anything from an auto salvage.
Finally, one woman, Marge Thompson, took the knife, clawed glove and hid it
in her basement as some kind of reassurance that it wouldn't fall back into
the wrong hands.
All seemed well for a few years, but then children started dying off again.
There is an In Memoriam section at the high school which seems to begin with
three deaths in 1975, seven years after Freddy was burned to death.
The problem just seemed to get worse from then on.
But I'd imagine that nothing could really be done because nobody knew what
was causing these deaths.
To an outsider, these may have appeared to be cases of SUNDS or
Sudden unexpected nocturnal death syndrome.
This was a phenomenon observed in Southeast Asian refugees in the early 80s
where seemingly healthy young men just died in their sleep.
This syndrome is actually what inspired Craven to write A Nightmare on Elm Street.
In an interview with Vulture, he recounted how he read about a boy
from Cambodia who was afraid he'd be attacked in his dreams and never wake up.
When he finally fell asleep, his parents thought this crisis was over.
Then they heard screams in the middle of the night.
By the time they got to him, he was dead.
He died in the middle of a nightmare.
While the adults didn't have much in the way of a logical explanation, the
kids passed down a nursery rhyme through each generation warning of the
haunting of Freddy.
-[Kids] One, two, Freddy’s coming for you. Three, four, better lock your door.
But the next line of the song is the most intriguing? Five, six, grab your crucifix.
Which seems to compare Freddy to some kind of antichrist figure
that you can protect yourself against using a cross, much like a vampire.
But is this the case or is it just urban legend? In March 1981, Nancy Thompson,
the daughter of the woman who confiscated Freddy's finger blade glove,
would find out for herself.
But this is the point where I have to pause and explain the timeline a
little bit more.
These movies don't often reference the date, so I had to do a little puzzle solving.
One of the few concrete dates is June 1989, when the graduation
ceremony occurs in A Nightmare in Elm Street 5.
From there, we can work backwards.
In Elm Street 4, Alice has a driver's license, so at the earliest, this
is 1987.
Kristen's tomb stone states that she was born in 1969 and she's still in
high school, which means at the latest, it's 1987.
So Elm Street 4 takes place in 1987.
And this is backed up by the poster for the movie Prison, which came out in 87.
A Nightmare in Elm Street 3 takes place a little bit before the
fourth one because in 4 they start school together in the fall.
So Dream Warriors is most likely spring or summer of that same year.
And in Dream Warriors, Nancy says this.
Roll it.
-[Nancy] Six years ago, he killed my friends.
Which means the original, A Nightmare on Elm Street took place in 1981.
And according to Nancy's diary, which is found in the second movie, the
weird dreams begin around March 15.
-[Jesse] March 15.
-[Jesse] He comes to me at night, horrible, ugly, dirty, under the sheets with me
-[Jesse] tearing at my nightgown with his steel claws.
-[Jesse] His name is Fred and he keeps trying to take me to the boiler room.
-[Jesse] He wants to kill me.
But why does he want to kill her? It's really pretty simple.
The more children's souls he collects, the more powerful he becomes.
And he also needs to make himself known as an urban legend in order to
strike fear into the town.
Because if people forget about him, he'll be in danger of losing the power
to invade dreams.
-[Freddy] The children still feared me and their fear gave me the power to invade
-[Freddy] their dreams.
So in March 1981, he chooses four new targets in his old neighborhood on Elm Street.
Nancy Thompson, Tina Grey, Rod Lane and Glen Lantz.
And each of them have dreams where Freddy begins his scare tactics.
Tina's dream includes the appearance of a lamb in a damp hallway which
represents the sacrificial lamb found in many religions a clue about her
becoming the first sacrifice of the friend group.
From there, she goes to the boiler room, which is Freddy's main domain.
She's cornered in front of a furnace, flames blazing behind her.
This room represents hell and Freddy represents the devil that presides over it.
Like something that could only happen in a nightmare.
Freddy suddenly appears behind her and she awakens with a scream, finding
her nightgown torn.
I think you could also look at the torn clothing as a more subtle way of
Craven including the detail about Freddy also being a different type of
predator when it comes to the minors that he's hunting.
Nancy and Rod both experience similar dreams that night.
So the next day, both couples stay at Tina's.
Nancy, at first glance, seems to be protected by the crucifix in the bedroom
that she's staying in because Freddy seems to retract after starting to
cross the threshold.
Tina, on the other hand, would not be so lucky and finds herself in another
nightmare scenario.
(IMPACT)
If you really want to fully understand everything there is to know about
Freddy Krueger it's important to also understand his creator, Wes Craven,
writer and director of the original movie.
And the best way to do this is to check out his biography,
Wes Craven The Man and His Nightmares, now available on Audible.
Starting from his childhood, this book takes you through the intricacies of
his career and personal life, including some lesser known details of
A Nightmare on Elm Street.
Right now, with my link, users can get a free trial of Audible.
As an Audible member, you get to choose one title a month to keep as a member.
You also get full access to a growing selection of included
audiobooks, Audible originals, and podcasts.
It's easy to download from any device with the Audible app, even yours.
It's the perfect way to create time to check out more titles, whether you're
relaxing on the go or multitasking, you can even listen to Audible to drown
out the mundanities of life and the incessant flow of time leading to your mortality.
But CZ, how do we get Audible free for 30 days? It's easy.
Just go to Audible.com/czsworld or text CZsWorld to 500-500, and then you
can figure it out from there.
That's Audible.com/czsworld
Or text CZsWorld to 500-500 for your free trial.
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Freddy lures Tina into an alley using a mysterious voice.
Then, after rolling a trash can lid in her direction to startle her, reveals
his horrifying appearance, arms extended unnaturally to scrape the wall with
his bladed glove.
Tina's first reaction is to seek help in god.
But Freddy, persistently in opposition to religion, mocks her god with his response.
–[Tina] Please God!
–[Freddy] THIS is God.
He chases her back to the house, demonstrating the ability to warp around
the dream scene, slice off his own fingers with no pain, and have his face
torn away.
Remember, he's been doing this for some time at this point, and has already
developed tricks to terrify and torture his victims using dream logic.
He pins her down and slashes her through the chest before
dragging and tossing her body all around the room.
The others are woken up by the commotion and don't manage to get any sleep
after seeing the scene.
So it isn't until the next day that Freddy is able to target Nancy, who falls
asleep in class.
Freddy is able to manipulate the dreams of his victims, so he causes Nancy
to see her best friend in a body bag, the first in a trail of breadcrumbs
that he uses to draw her in.
He shape shifts into a hall monitor, who she runs into on her way to the basement,
which turns out to be none other than Freddy's boiler room.
The school basement never disappoints in a horror movie.
I remember when I was in high school, on one of the last days, I was just
walking around, not in class, and I saw the principal walking around and
asked him to show me the basement, the one place in the school that I had
never seen.
And he did.
He didn't even question why I wasn't in class.
And it just goes to show, sometimes you just gotta ask for things,
Like asking you to subscribe.
Freddy emerges from behind the boiler and slices his own chest, just as he
used to as a boy.
But this time, it reveals maggots and green ooze.
He laughs maniacally as he chases her around.
But unlike Tina, Nancy manages to wake herself up at the end by reaching for
a hot pipe.
But thanks to the power given to him by the dream demons, any injuries that
he dishes out in dreams also carry through to real life.
And Nancy wakes up realizing that the burn is real.
Not to be deterred, Freddy continues to haunt Nancy's dreams whenever she falls asleep,
like when she dozes off in the bathtub and he pulls her under the surface,
once again hinting at that metaphor that the studio didn't want
to include blatantly.
In another dream, Freddy visits Rod, who's being held in jail as
a suspect in Tina's death.
He gives chase, continuing to use images of Tina to torture her.
But ultimately Nancy's alarm clock saves her, perhaps wanting an easier target,
or perhaps realizing it'll have a psychological effect on Nancy if
another one of her friends dies.
Freddy turns his efforts to Rod, kills him in his dream and stages it as a suicide.
He goes for another round with Nancy after this.
However, I don't have the details because we see this dream from an outside
perspective while Nancy is being studied at the Katja Sleep Institute.
However, it must have been pretty traumatic because she wakes up with a
fresh trio of cuts on her arm, a strand of gray hair and a souvenir.
– [Nancy] I brought something out from my dream.
At some point the next night, Freddy calls the phone in her bedroom.
She's expecting to hear from her boyfriend Glen, but it turns out to be
more of a nuisance call.
–[Freddy] I’m your boyfriend now, Nancy!
A tongue protrudes out of the receiver and licks her, causing her to spike
the phone and destroy it.
That's still preferred to getting a telemarketer though.
It wouldn't be the last time that Freddy used his tongue to freak out a victim.
And it all ties into the inappropriate subtext of his character.
But Nancy isn't even asleep for this.
So how did Freddy get to her in the waking world?
At this point, Nancy is running out empty.
She's mostly stayed awake twenty four seven for the last few days, and her
body really needs sleep.
There's something called hypnogogic hallucination, also known as waking dreams.
These are brief hallucinations that take place as you're falling asleep.
They can be visual, auditory or physical.
You may have experienced this in a minor capacity.
You're about to fall asleep and you hear someone say your name, but there's
nobody there.
Or you hear your phone buzz, but there's no notification.
Now that I've looked into hypnogogic hallucination, I actually think it may
explain a mystery that's always haunted me.
I used to do production sound for movies and video, and in one indie film
that I did, they were putting us up in an airbnb and I got stuck rooming
with this guy that snored super loud.
Like incredibly loud.
You would not believe how loud it was if you heard it in person.
So it was kind of hard to fall asleep.
But just as I was finally falling asleep, I feel myself get bounced, like
someone had jumped on the air mattress I was sleeping on.
So immediately I wake up and I look around and there's nobody there.
The guy's still snoring on the other side of the room and there was no one
else around.
I'm not a believer when it comes to ghosts, but I'd never been able to
explain that one until I learned about waking dreams, which can include
physical hallucinations as well.
So I think that's what's happening to Nancy here.
Her body is shutting down, and those hallucinations are starting to happen
while she's still awake, allowing Freddy to affect her in the real world in
a minor way.
But meanwhile, across the street, Glen has fully fallen asleep.
And just like Nancy was pulled underwater in the bath, Freddy pulls Glen
down into a void in his bed.
Moments before, a fountain of blood explodes from it, completely repainting
the ceiling of his room.
With all three of Nancy's friends now dead, Freddy uses them against her as
she intentionally travels back into dreamland, hoping to bring Freddy out
into the real world with her.
As she travels down into the boiler room, she hears echoes of her dead
friends calling to her and Freddy's laughter as he taunts her.
–[Freddy] I’m gonna get you!
He stalks her from around corners as she goes deeper into the boiler room,
eventually chasing her through dream space back to her house.
But to his surprise, instead of running from him, she tackles him just
before her alarm goes off and takes her back to the world of the awake.
I don't want to get too picky here, because none of this is real, but I feel
like if Freddy Krueger was real that this plan wouldn't work, because clocks
never seem to work properly in a dream.
And also you can have a dream that feels really long, but it was actually
pretty short in real world time.
They do an amazing job of conceptualizing this in the movie Inception.
Anyway, Freddy is carried through back into the real world for the first
time in 13 years, but that's not going to stop him from going after her.
Only he finds that in this world, everything has been rigged with traps.
He opens a locked door, only to be gut checked with a hammer, trips over a
wire that sets off an exploding light bulb, and gets bombarded with a jug of
kerosene to set the stage for a Freddy flavored barbecue.
But this is nothing that he hasn't dealt with before.
The now flaming Freddy stays hot on her heels, literally, but he's door
checked back down the stairs.
Still, he's somehow able to break out of the basement and sneak past Nancy
up the stairs and into the room of Nancy's mother, Marge, one of the parents
responsible for killing him the first time and stealing his glove.
Still ablaze, he strangles her in her sleep until Nancy finds him and breaks a
chair over his back.
But when the flames are extinguished by Nancy's dad, they see Marge's
charred remains sink back into the dreamscape, with Freddy nowhere to be found.
My interpretation is that since Freddy found Marge asleep, he was
able to use her to escape back into the world of dreams, taking her life in
the process.
But this battle is not over yet.
As Nancy takes a moment to herself in her room, Freddy takes the opportunity
to stretch the fabric of reality and apparently the fabric of this bedsheet
once more.
But this time, Nancy seems to have him figured out.
–[Freddy]You think you was gonna get away from me?
–[Nancy] I know you too well now Freddy.
Nancy is finally able to divest him of his power by turning away and
depriving him of the energy he needs, by refusing to believe he's real or be afraid.
As he tries to stab her in the back, he disintegrates into a cosmic
shadow and disappears.
As I mentioned a lot, the rules tend to change a lot in this franchise, but
there are a few other moments that are consistent with Freddy's defeat here.
In A Nightmare on Elm Street 2, Nancy further explains how she
eventually beat Freddy on the last page of her diary.
-[Lisa] He is evil itself.
-[Lisa] I know now that I brought him into my world.
-[Lisa] We all did.
-[Lisa] Gave him all the energy he needed.
-[Lisa] Our screams were all he needed.
The concept is touched on again in Freddy vs. Jason,
which we'll get to.
Despite seeming to find the key to fend off Freddy, Nancy's defense would
not stand forever.
–[Nancy] No!!! Mother!!
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
After nearly trapping Nancy in his nightmare convertible, she was somehow
able to escape Freddy's grasp and wake up again.
She was quickly becoming his greatest rival.
But that rivalry would be interrupted because in the aftermath of Freddy's
1981 rampage, Nancy was determined to have gone crazy.
Or at least that's the story that circulated the town.
-[Ron] Some chick was locked in there by her mother and she went crazy.
She was put on an experimental dream suppression drug known as Hypnocil, and
surprisingly, this seemed to do the trick.
With no more dreams, Freddy had no way to access her, and he eventually had
to move on to a new target.
It would appear that none of these other kids gave him quite as much trouble
as Nancy had.
Remember, these names in the In Memorium are just the high school fatalities
and don't account for any kids of other ages.
But he claimed at least six more teens in 1982, at least seven in 1983, and
literally pages worth in 84 and 85.
The next notable victim to put up enough of a fight to warrant the creation
of another Nightmare on Elm Street movie came in 1986, five years after the
Nancy Thompson showdown.
-[Lisa] You know this thing is five years old?
-[Jesse] You know her?
-[Lisa] No, before my time.
A man named Ken Walsh buys the vacant house.
The now infamous 1428 Elm Street, and his son, Jesse Walsh, takes up
residence in Nancy's old room.
It doesn't take long for his dreams to go dark, including one where Freddy
is a school bus driver who drives them into a giant fissure to hell.
And one where he sees Freddy retrieving the finger blade glove from the boiler
in the basement and asks for his help on some special work.
-[Freddy] I need you Jesse. We’ve got special work to do here.
-[Freddy] You and me.
-[Freddy] You've got the body, I've got the brain.
Necessary information, Jesse is gay.
So Krueger's remarks here are once again playing into those psychosexual themes
which I talk about more in my Things You Missed episode on Freddy's Revenge.
But to quickly sum it up, the Jesse arc follows different rules
than the Nancy arc.
And this time, Freddy's goal is to take over Jesse's body and make him do
the killing as a metaphor for the shame that Jesse feels by still being
closeted about his sexuality.
This comes out again the next night when Jesse has a dream where it's so hot
that everything in his room is melting.
So he goes to the basement, where he finds Freddy's glove hidden in the furnace,
and Freddy encourages him to try putting it on and killing.
The following evening, the Walsh's pet bird breaks out of its cage, flies
around, attacks the family, then bursts into flame.
-[Ken] There’s got to be a rational explanation.
-[Ken] I mean, animals don’t just explode into flames for no reason.
Excellent observation, Ken.
The moment also represents the point where Freddy isn't just limited to
dreams anymore.
For some reason.
His next move comes later that night.
While Jesse's gym teacher is making him run laps as punishment for sneaking
into a bar, Freddy brings all the gym equipment to life and uses it to
attack the coach, eventually tying him up with a jump rope before taking
control of Jesse's body and using it to slash Coach Schneider in the back.
When the fog clears, Jesse finds himself wearing the glove that he found the
other night.
He screams when he realizes what he's done, which suggests that this time
Freddy is using his powers to simulate another sleep phenomena, Somnambulism.
More commonly known as sleepwalking.
But once again, it's not very realistic that Freddy would be able to control
a sleepwalker.
Sleepwalking occurs during non REM sleep, during which there are no dreams.
So when someone sleepwalks, they aren't actually acting out their dreams.
It's more of a misfired signal in the brain.
But we have seen Freddy demonstrate an ability to toss around someone whose
dream he's invading, like what happened with Tina and Glen, for example.
So maybe he's just doing that in a more controlled way to manipulate Jesse
into doing whatever he wants.
More weird nightmares would follow.
The next night, he found Freddy's glove moving on its own in the drawer and
even dreamt of his own sister jump roping while singing the Freddy Krueger
nursery rhyme.
In the morning, their toaster catches fire, even though it's not plugged in.
-[Ken] Craziest damn thing I've ever seen.
Dad, what about the bird that exploded yesterday?
In the evening, Freddy possesses Jesse's body again, and he visits his sister's room.
But when he speaks out to her, Freddy's voice comes out.
-[Freddy] Wake up, little girl.
So then she does wake up.
Clearly sees her brother standing there and asks what time it is.
And when he tells her, it's in Jesse's voice again because she's no longer asleep.
–[Jesse] It’s late, go back to sleep.
So which one is it? You want her to wake up or go to sleep? Make up your mind.
Now, up until this point, Freddy has kind of been able to fly under
the radar.
Some of his victims drew a big police presence.
But because he only takes one victim at a time, and because all of his
victims are asleep, there are only a couple witnesses who know that he's
behind it.
That would all change soon, because Lee Lisa Weber, a girl from Jesse's
school who has a crush on him, holds a big pool party and, of course,
invites Jesse.
She tries to get it on with him in the cabana.
But Freddy demonstrates his control by once again materializing a huge,
rotting tongue in the real world.
For Jesse, this represents his true sexuality, which he's trying to hide.
So when he realizes he's unable to control it, he gets out of there, which
is actually smart.
Good job, Jesse.
Except he goes to visit the boy he most likely has an eye on Grady, which
was not smart, because as he's there, he literally sees himself transform
into Freddy, which is an agonizing process for him.
Jesse or Freddy.
It's not really clear which one Grady can actually see.
Puts on the finger blade, glove and gashes right through him as he bangs on
the door for help.
Rip. Grady.
With the floodgates now open for Freddy to manipulate stuff in the real world,
he goes back to sabotage the pool party, locking everyone in, blowing
up the lights, heating the pool to the point of boiling, and worst of all,
setting all the hot dogs on fire.
Meanwhile, inside, Freddy takes over Jesse's body and attacks Lisa.
He starts eating her leg for some reason, okay? But she gets away and tries
to call out to Jesse, believing that he's still in there somewhere.
She actually gets through to him, but it's clear that he's given up hope.
-[Jesse] Kill me, Lisa.
-[Jesse] Please kill me.
And since Freddy's only real goal is to kill people and harvest souls, he
just finds this amusing.
♪ I heard a knock upon my door the other day ♪
Natural reaction.
Lisa stabs him in the shoulder.
But even in the real world, that does no good.
This is the same guy who used to cut himself all day for fun.
He throws Lisa against the wall, but for now, he's gonna let her live.
It's always hard for me to analyze his actions when they don't make any
sense. But here goes.
Freddy knew that Lisa loved Jesse, so he didn't see her as a threat and
decided to go after the other guests at the pool party first.
Everyone outside is confused by the commotion.
Then this happens...
–[Party Guest] What’s going on?
(Freddy bursts through the deck)
During this onslaught, nobody can escape because they're locked in and the
fence is burning hot.
Chaos ensues, the pool catches fire, and at least four teens are killed
before Lisa's dad makes it outside with his gun.
But knowing that Jesse is still in there somewhere, lisa actually prevents
him from firing at Freddy.
I guess the decision to keep her alive paid off for him, at least in the
short term.
Perhaps realizing the situation, though, like, that he could potentially get
shot and die in the real world.
He just walks to the edge of the party and bursts into flames.
Nightmare 2 makes no sense. I tried, okay?
He goes back to his old base of operations, the boiler room
at the now abandoned power plant, but soon finds that he's not alone.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
It isn't long before Freddy realizes he has a visitor.
Lisa is still determined to get back her friend and crush Jesse.
So Freddy stalks her from afar and tortures her with a series of
hallucinations before aggressively appearing before her and nearly slicing
her face open.
-[Lisa] Jesse, I know you're in there.
-[Lisa] Stop him.
-[Freddy] No. Jesse's dead.
He's about to finish her off when Lisa hears Jesse's voice and confesses
her love for him.
And this actually seems to physically hurt Freddy.
For example, the spot that she stabbed him in earlier starts bleeding.
And the more she says she loves him, the more pain he seems to be in.
Lisa kisses him, and Freddy goes up in flame.
His skin burns away, and he turns back into Jesse.
Sticking with the sexuality metaphor, this is Jesse taking back hold of his
ability to repress his feelings.
He knows he'll hurt Lisa if he comes out.
He knows people in his life will be ashamed of him.
That's just the reality of the time period he lives in.
So he's gotta get control of it.
And in a literal sense, he gets control of Freddy, the hidden monster that
is manipulating his actions.
But like Nancy, five years before, the victory is only temporary.
And before Jesse goes back to school, he dreams of another runaway bus where
Freddy's hand bursts out of the classmate's chest and presumably makes good
on his earlier promise and finishes him off.
After 1986, the records of kids who died are not as well kept, because it
seems like it's just become such a common thing that the school can't even
keep up with it.
We do find out about a kid in early 1987 who is most likely a Freddy victim.
-[Dr. Gordon] We lost a kid about a month ago to Fairview.
-[Dr. Gordon] I don't know where he got the razors, but he cut off his own eyelids to stay awake.
That's funny.
I did the same thing when I was trying to make it through watching the
Nightmare on Elm Street remake.
At some point, Freddy finished taking out most all of the kids with
connections to the group of parents who killed him in 1968, but there were a
few leftovers who no longer lived there.
These kids survived their first encounters with Freddy, but still incurred
injuries during their nightmares, which made it look like they had each
attempt did suicide.
One example is Kristen Parker, most likely in spring 1987.
Kristen dreamed that she was outside 1428 Elm Street and tried to save a
little girl who wandered inside.
As she tries to fend off Freddy in her dream, he manipulates things in the
real world so that it looks like she slit her wrist.
Her mom catches her and sends her to Westin Hills Psychiatric Hospital,
where she joins several other kids who were deemed to be suicidal because of
their encounters with Freddy.
They were essentially held there against their will, but clearly, they were
lucky to be alive.
-[Reporter] And in local news, two more teenage deaths have occurred, both suicides.
-[Reporter] County health officials are at a loss to explain this alarming trend.
For Freddy, there are pros and cons to this strategy.
On one hand, he can continue to consume more souls while covering up each
death as something else, meaning his victims will be less informed and less
prepared to fight him.
The downside is that the public doesn't credit him with each kill, and the
town's belief in him and fear of him is part of what gives him power, as we
saw with Nancy.
And speaking of Nancy, Freddy's greatest rival would resurface as a
therapist at Western Hill, as a survivor, she's the only one who can help
the kids who are captive there, because she's the only one who believes them.
During Kristen's next nightmare, she's attacked by a giant worm
incarnation of Freddy, and she pulls Nancy into her dream.
Nancy finds a glass shard and stabs the creature in the eye, allowing
Kristen to get free.
When Freddy sees Nancy's face, he recognizes her as the one who got away.
-[Freddy] You…
Kristen was able to pull Nancy into her dream because of a unique ability
she has, which would create a new challenge for the Springwood Slasher.
Previously, he'd never really had to worry about his victims teaming up on him.
The worst they could do was stand by to wake someone up if they sensed
a nightmare.
Kristen's ability made her especially dangerous, allowing the kids to fight
back together.
So Freddy got to work, taking out each of her friends in their own
individual dreams.
One patient, Philip, is an amateur puppeteer.
So Freddy enters his dream and turns him into a human puppet, using his
veins as strings, marching him to a third floor window and cutting him
loose, causing him to fall to his death in both,
the dream and the real world. Probably the most disturbing and
creative kill in all of Freddy's history.
The next night, he goes after Jennifer, an aspiring TV star, and pulls her
head through the TV in her room.
–[Freddy] Welcome to primetime b*tch!
During a group hypnosis session, shortly after,
a mute patient named Joey wanders away from the group when he
is distracted by a nurse that he has a crush on.
Wait, Joey? She's a trap? Yeah.
It turns out to be Freddy, who shoves his giant tongue down the kid's throat,
then uses it to restrain him above the bed, which falls away into a
giant pit of fire.
It's always the tongue with this guy.
I swear, I could do a whole video on just the history of Freddy Krueger's tongue.
I'm getting flashbacks to the Grimace video at this point.
It once again hints at the two themes that I keep coming back to.
Freddy is implied to be a predator through his actions, and he's associated
with the devil by suspending Joey over what is essentially a pit to hell.
-[Ganon] No! Not into the pit!
-[Ganon] It burns.
Meanwhile, all the other patients are together in the group session,
discovering how they can be whoever they want to in their dreams.
-[Taryn In my dreams, I'm beautiful and bad.
Uh, okay.
Whatever you say.
Freddy traps them using the same tactic he used at the pool party the
previous year.
When they try to escape, they realize the doorknobs are burning hot.
Kind of an inconsistency, because in the first movie, touching something hot
would wake you up.
But maybe this is different because these kids are in a hypnosis.
The room transforms into an industrial silo type thing, but luckily, a
doctor discovers the sleeping group.
However, because Joey was trapped by Krueger in the dream, he's unable to
awaken, and he falls into a deep coma.
It would be easy for him to just kill Joey at this point and take his soul,
but Freddy wants revenge on Nancy for getting the best of him six years
prior and uses Joey as a hostage.
Kristen pulls everyone into the dream world to save him, but they're
immediately ambushed and sent into their own little breakout dreams.
Kristen dreams about her mother bringing home a guest who turns out to be
Freddy in a bow tie, but she's able to use some parkour moves to escape.
Taryn finds herself in an alley, where she notices some graffiti that says
Taryn plus Freddy enclosed in a heart.
Once again, Freddy is inappropriately tying himself to these kids in a
romantic context.
This would continue throughout the rest of Freddy's history.
He takes the form of a pin up model, asks the girl if she wants to suck face,
asks the girl if she wants to make babies, and even takes the form of
another predator.
Look, I'm not Chris Hansen.
I'm not gonna point out every single time he does something like this.
You get the idea.
Freddy starts to use each kid's weaknesses against them.
Taryn is a former addict, so Freddy transforms his finger blades into
syringes, which he plunges into her.
Will is disabled, in the real world.
He can only walk in his dream, so Freddy runs him down
with what I can only describe as a giant BDSM wheelchair.
He tries to conjure up some dream magic to destroy the chair and vanquish Freddy,
but it's not enough to do anything.
–[Freddy] Sorry kid. I don’t believe in fairy tales.
It's cool to see Freddy evolving as a villain.
In the beginning, he just terrorized Nancy and her friends with generic
nightmare stuff, but now he's learned to tailor each nightmare towards
whoever he's going after.
The evolution fits nicely because it makes it all that more important for
the remaining survivors to team up if they want to have a chance against him.
They have strength in numbers because he can only tailor the nightmare
to fit one person.
But unfortunately for the group, there is only one person that he wants more
than anyone, and their showdown would be six years in the making.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
The group finds Joey in the boiler room, which looks even more like an
underworld realm than ever before.
With their friends suspended over an even deeper hell pit, Freddy confronts Nancy,
who foolishly demands that he let Joey go, and she has to run to save
him from falling into the pit.
This gives Krueger the perfect opportunity to push her in, but her new
friends come to her rescue.
Kristen knocks him back with a flying jump tackle.
-[Seanthedeanzastudent] Okay, Angus is gonna knock down these chips using a flying jump tackle.
Like I said, flying jump tackle.
And Kincaid smashes him over the head with a giant metal pipe.
I also like how Kincaid's dream power is just him being strong, even though
he already is strong in the real world.
However, Krueger is able to stop him and lift him into the
air with one arm while choking him.
But their teamwork continues to be their advantage as Nancy finds a metal
stake and thrusts it through Freddy's gut, which surprises him, but he
simply laughs and pulls it out.
Nancy comments on how he's never been this strong, and Freddy shows her why
by revealing the screaming souls of the children that give him strength,
meaning that with each victim he takes, he gets more and more powerful in
the dream world.
Keep that in mind, because it's gonna explain some anomalies later.
But even with this additional power, he's not able to finish off Kincaid
because he vanishes to go fight another battle.
Apparently, he can only be in one place at a time, and he's got to go clash
with one of the doctors from the hospital and Nancy's dad, who are together
trying to bury his bones in the real world.
They believe laying Freddy's bones to rest will end his curse.
They're basically completely wrong about this.
But for whatever reason, Freddy still wants to defend his bones.
So he brings them to life and engages in combat as skelly Freddy.
Maybe the reason for this is because it was his one chance to finally
get back at Nancy's dad, one of the parents who lynched him 19 years prior.
And he does just that, throwing Donald into a stake and impaling him.
He also manages to knock out the doctor and does a little celebratory emote.
I actually had to do a double take right here because I thought I was seeing
actual footage of me whenever I have a video pop off.
With that threat taken care of, Freddy returns to the dream world and freaks
out the kids using a hall of mirrors, which very much needs to be a room if
they ever do another Dream Warriors maze at Horror Nights.
Each of them is pulled into a separate mirror, but Joey
saves the day by screaming out for the first time and shattering the glass
to save them, which seems to hurt Freddy as well.
But he has one more trick up his striped sleeve.
This time, he takes the form of Nancy's father, as if he's entering the
dream world to tell her that he's crossed over.
And this honestly doesn't make sense.
You're not dreaming if you're dead, but it's enough to trick Nancy into
letting her guard down.
He turns back into Freddy and stabs her in the stomach.
It looks like it may be over for the rest of the Dream Warriors as well.
But with the last of her strength, Nancy jumps on his back and drives his
own finger blades into his chest.
And for the first time, Freddy is beaten on his home turf.
But in the end, Nancy's sacrifice would basically go in vain, because
there's still a light on at 1428 Elm Street.
The survivors, Kristen. Kincaid and Joey, did get a little break from their
striped sweatered saboteur, but when they went back to school that fall,
Kristen began to see signs of his return.
Yes, this is Kristen now.
She got a makeover, okay.
She also got a boyfriend named Rick.
I personally wouldn't be rushing out to date the new girl fresh out of a
psychiatric hospital, but Rick doesn't seem to mind.
In fact, they are so in love that they apparently don't notice this huge,
glowing slash in the lockers.
More evidence of Freddy's imminent return.
And that return would become a reality that evening when Kincaid has a dream
about the auto salvage where Freddy's bones were buried earlier that year.
He sees his dog prodding at the burial spot and goes to take a piss, but
instead emits a stream of flame.
And Kincaid watches as crevices in the earth open up to make way for
Freddy's reassembly.
His flesh rots in reverse until his true hellish form is
completely restored.
–[Freddy] You shouldn’t have buried me, I’m not dead.
No, actually, he is dead.
But as long as the dream demons still reside within him, he has the ability
to come back and haunt more teenage dreams.
So even when Kincaid pushes a car from above to crush him.
He just responds again, and eventually, Kincaid's luck runs out, and he gets
a gut full of finger blades.
So at this point, there's not much for me to analyze.
It's pretty obvious that no amount of killing Freddy in the dream world will
ever do away with him, and it would be some time before anyone else figures
out how to bring him out into the real world.
His immediate goal is to finish off the Elm Street children that managed to
escape him at Westin Hills.
After Kincaid, that continues with Joey, who is once again tricked by Freddy
taking the form of his crush, this time a pin up model from a poster
before he's pulled down into his waterbed.
Kind of similar to what happened to Nancy in the bathtub.
Kristen tries to dream about a place that Freddy would never go and finds
herself at the beach, but Freddy's glove emerges from the water like a shark
fin, not even hitting land slows it down
and with a blast, she finds her worst nightmare standing
before her with some pretty stylish shades, but not as stylish as my YouTube specs.
Alice's choice of venue ends up working against her when Freddy
manipulates the dream, turning beach sand into quicksand.
But as Kristen sinks down, she emerges in a decayed Elm Street house and
soon finds herself in the boiler room.
Fittingly, he was chasing her to the spot where he had ended the lives of so
many of the neighborhood's kids before her.
–[Freddy] Elm Street’s last brat. Farewell.
And there's a good reason he allowed her to be the last survivor.
He didn't want her to use her special ability to pull in any Dream Warrior
reinforcements, as she had in the past, but due to her fear, she
accidentally pulls someone into her dream anyway.
This is Alice Johnson, Kristen's classmate and the sister of her boyfriend.
Realizing her mistake, Kristen tries to shield the innocent Alice by
attacking Freddy, but he effortlessly grabs her and hurls her into the
raging furnace, certainly one of the most brutal ways to go since Freddy
himself was burned to death.
It's a moment of closure for him.
The last links to the Elm Street families who killed him would go out the
same way that he did.
He proudly displays his collection of tortured souls in preparation for
absorbing Kristen, but even in death, she proves to be difficult, and
instead of being absorbed by him, she passes through his body to Alice in
order to pass her dream powers on to her friend.
Upon waking, Alice sees a new postcard on her mirror, Greetings From Hell!
And as we've come to expect, Freddy is holding Kristen almost like a lover.
Alice and Rick rush over to Kristen's house to find her room already in flames.
It was too late to save her, so that was it.
The Elm Street parents tried to get their revenge on Freddy, but in the end,
he won, finishing off every last one of their descendants.
But that didn't mean he was about to step away and quietly begin his retirement.
And I can actually relate to this.
When I first started getting serious about YouTube, my goal was to reach
10,000 subscribers.
But when I did that, that silver plaque started looking not so out of reach.
So I went for 100,000 subscribers.
And when I got that, the glint of gold caught my eye, and I thought for sure
I'd chill out after a million.
And at first, I did.
But then I started to develop new goals, some of which you'll find out about
in about a month.
I think I've learned that if you have that drive to succeed, you're never
going to be fully satisfied.
And Freddy definitely has that drive.
Maybe that's why the Dream Demons chose him.
After eliminating the last of the Elm Street kids, he would broaden his hunt
to the entire town of Springwood.
(IMPACT)
♪ Static Music ♪
At Westin Hills,
Freddy used each of the kids' weaknesses against them, so as he turned his
attention to the entire city, he decided to have some fun and toy with their
fears as well.
The first victim is Alice's asthmatic friend Sheila, who's worried about her
astrology test when she dozes off.
During it, Freddy sucks the oxygen out of her skull, causing her eyes to
sink in and her skin to dry up.
Rick is still struggling with grief over his girlfriend's death, and he
apparently falls asleep on the toilet and sees Freddy use the form of
Kristen to entice him before scaring the crap out of him.
Pun actually not intended, believe it or not.
The bathroom stall turns into an elevator ride down to a Japanese dojo,
which for some reason, is decorated with an early prototype of the IGN logo.
Rick's karate skills actually help him get the better of Freddy, but Krueger
takes a cheap shot by launching his glove into his opponent before he can react.
Alice's next dream features her getting sucked into the screen a
movie theater, which lands her at her place of work.
Her biggest fear is waiting tables her entire life.
So Freddy shows her imagery of an older version of herself still working there.
But when he appears at the counter next to her, he doesn't try to
kill her.
And there's a reason for it, which is demonstrated when the older version of
Alice brings him a pizza topped with meatballs resembling the souls of his victims.
Because of her uncontrolled new ability to pull others into her dreams,
Alice is essentially serving her friends right up to Freddy.
And next in line is her friend Deb, whose greatest fear became cockroaches
after she found one in her food earlier that week.
Nobody show her The Babadook. Okay?
During her workout session, she finds she has an unexpected spotter,
who pushes her barbell down and snaps her elbows.
Roach like appendages jut out from her broken arms, and she slowly turns
into an insect and finds that she's a prisoner in a giant bug trap.
It's a new twist on the commonly reported nightmare of running in slow
motion which we saw before with Nancy and Kristen.
Freddy watches through a small hole as she becomes her own worst nightmare
then crushes her inside the roach motel.
He also does something that we've never seen him do before.
In order to prevent Alice and her love interest, Dan, from interfering he
puts them in an infinite loop where they meet up at the diner then go to
save Deb but just keep resetting back to the diner, where they have to start
all over again.
What they're experiencing is another representation of a real world sleep
phenomena known as a false awakening loop.
Most people have experienced this to some extent.
You're dreaming, and then you wake up and start going through your morning routine.
Then you actually wake up and realize it was all a dream.
For most, this will only happen once but for others, it can happen, like,
ten times hence the name false awakening loop.
As with everything related to dreams, we only have theories about why this happens.
No hard scientific conclusion.
For normal people, it's often associated with anxiety, for an
important event, like a job interview or like Halloween, that's an
important event.
In Alice's case, she may be stressed out about saving her friend.
Others have suggested that small noises or interruptions can interrupt your
REM sleep without fully waking you up causing your dream to reset to
something familiar.
Another theory is the protoconsciousness theory which is basically the idea
that your brain is trying to prepare you for the real world by showing you a
dream similar to your reality.
This obviously wouldn't apply to Alice because she's not the only one
manipulating her dreams.
There's evidence to suggest a link between false awakenings and lucid dreams.
Lucid dreams are just when you're dreaming but you know that you're dreaming.
So the false awakening could be your brain trying to trick you
into thinking that you're not dreaming.
This is much more likely what's going on with Alice and Dan.
Each time the dream resets they don't realize that they're dreaming until
several repetitions in when they finally figure it out.
Again, I have to give credit to the movie Inception for conceptualizing this so well.
The protagonist, Cobb is essentially a professional lucid dreamer,
He uses totems to help him determine if he's dreaming or not.
-[Cobb] This one was hers.
-[Cobb] She'd spin it in the dream.
-[Cobb] It would never talk.
But there's a chilling concern that rises throughout the movie.
That he may be getting lost in an infinite dream without realizing it.
Personally, I find that idea more haunting than Freddy Krueger ever could be.
But in Alice and Dan's case, they do escape from the dream
When Freddy breaks the loop by appearing in the middle of the road.
Alice tries to vehicular manslaughter him.
But when she crashes into him.
It's like hitting a bollard and the truck is crushed like a can.
They wake up, realizing they've crashed into a tree.
Dan is rushed to the hospital, where he's put under and has to deal with the
dreams about Freddy Krueger as his surgeon.
But Alice is okay and intentionally goes to sleep so she can try to enter
his dream and save him.
She's able to stall long enough for Dan to wake up, thus making him
disappear from the dream to safety which should technically be the end of
the dream because it was his dream to begin with, I think.
But in light of the constantly changing rules in the Elm Street franchise,
the nightmare continues and Alice finds herself in a church face to face
with the devil himself.
She fully realizes her title as the dream master by combining all of her
friend's talents to fight Freddy.
She uses Kristen's gymnastics, Rick's karate, Debbie's strength and Sheila's technology.
But as we've seen before, Freddy can easily heal himself.
–[Freddy] I. Am. Eternal.
And this is true.
It's very well established that you can't kill Freddy in the dream world.
But what Alice does is essentially the next best thing.
Using a broken shard of stained glass, she forces him to look his reflection
and he sees all of the screaming souls of his victims trapped inside of him.
This causes him immense pain.
Alice hits him with a blast of light and an arm bursts out from within him
as the souls of the dead attempt to climb their way out of his confines.
The very souls that gave him power are now keeping him pinned down against a trellis.
And finally his face bursts open allowing each of them to escape
freely into the night, thanking Alice for finally ending their suffering.
Although Freddy's skin, his sweater and his glove are left in to keep on
the ground and things do go back to normal for a short while, it's only a
matter of time before the nightmares would return.
–[Kids] Nine, ten, he’s back again.
Shortly before her high school graduation in June 1989, Alice would begin
seeing visions in her dreams detailing the conception and birth of
Frederick Krueger at the insane asylum.
The last of these dreams shows him being reborn and growing up into his
former glory.
When she wakes up, there's one thing she's most confused about.
-[Alice] It was Krueger.
-[Alice] It happened while I was awake. Do you understand what I'm saying?
How could Freddy be terrorizing her dreams,
if she wasn't even asleep? This was a sly move by the
Fedora Fatality Framer.
Yes. I'm running out of ways to introduce this character.
As you can see, we've been going for quite a while now.
It was not her dreams that were playing host to Freddy, but rather the
dreams of her unborn son who Freddy had found while hiding out inside her.
She did not know it yet, but Dan had gotten her pregnant.
And according to this one doctor later in the movie, an unborn fetus spends
up to 70% of its time dreaming.
Since it is literally my job to overthink everything, I did do that once again.
I looked at a number of articles which all seem to agree that
while we don't know for sure, it is likely that fetuses can dream.
And I think that's believable.
But my issue isn't about whether they can dream or not, it's the idea that
they would be able to dream up scenes of the outside world.
I imagine fetus dreams would be more of a series of sounds,
temperature shifts and other sensory changes.
However, we do know that Krueger has the ability to manipulate dreams, so
maybe he's able to introduce a visual aspect, keep that in mind.
But once again, this is all just theoretical, as with everything I've talked
about in this video related to dream science because we have technology that
can measure brain activity, but we don't have any tech that can record
dreams as the dreamer sees them.
And when it comes to remembering our dreams, our memories are very unreliable.
Even if you remember your dream, you probably don't remember all
of it.
The hippocampus, the part of our brains that's responsible for storing memory,
is not fully active during sleep and it takes some time to get going
after you wake up.
That's why it's so easy to forget about your dream if you don't write it
down right away.
That could be why nightmares are oftentimes more memorable than dreams.
Nightmares simulate danger, causing our survival instincts to kick in and
wake up the hippocampus.
But going off memory is still pretty unreliable for those trying to study dreams.
So until there's a way to record dreams, we'll likely never know
what a fetus sees while it's dreaming.
Which for now is good news if you're Freddy Krueger, who would continue his
spree with a set of new victims.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Despite losing some of his power a couple years earlier, Freddy is still well
equipped to dish out chaos in the dreams of Springwood's teenage population.
He finally gets to Dan, who's pulled into a dream while driving and crashes
his car.
Although he survives, he has the bright idea of switching to a motorcycle
which is hijacked by a very terminator looking Freddy and sent out of
control into oncoming traffic.
Next he goes for members of Alice's new friend group.
Greta is a student whose mother is pushing her to become a model, often
criticizing her for her diet.
Freddy pulls her into a dream during a dinner party and force feeds her to
the point of asphyxiation.
Mark is a comic book artist who is suddenly possessed to draw 1428 Elm Street.
He is pulled into his own drawing and nearly sucked into the birth
canal where Freddy is hiding.
But Alice gets there in time to save him.
Yvonne, a member of the diving team, also has a close call at practice when
the diving board below her breaks apart and the pool transforms into this
puddle that transports her to what appears to be the inside of the boiler.
She's seized by Freddy,
But Alice once again comes to the rescue, impaling Freddy through the mouth
with the wrong end of a pool net.
All the while, Alice experiences several dreams featuring a young boy named Jacob,
who she eventually comes to realize is a representation of her unborn
son when she's pulled into a dream inside her own womb during an ultrasound
and sees Freddy feeding the souls that he's collected to the baby.
He's taking their souls, their spirit, and making the baby like him.
I know we should probably be past the point of questioning when the rules of
the Elm Street universe change, but seriously, does the baby dream about the
real world or does the baby dream about the womb? Just pick one.
The next victim is Mark, who is just kicking back and reading some comic books,
but discovers that Freddy has taken over the pages with scenes of his
friends being attacked.
Once again, he's pulled into the world of the comic.
He takes a page from the Dream Warriors by demonstrating a unique dream ability,
and turns himself into one of his super powered characters.
But Freddy does the same, emerging in this comic book villain looking
costume and referring to himself as Super Freddy.
I guess we can give this one points for creativity, but it really feels like
Freddy, and by extension, the creators of these movies, kind of forgot to
try to be scary at some point.
And it certainly doesn't help when Mark loses his three dimensional volume
and Freddy simply shreds him into scrap paper.
However, I am still highly anticipating Paper Freddy and The Thousand Year Door.
With Yvonne and Alice as the two remaining survivors.
Yvonne goes to look for the lost remains of Amanda Krueger, while Alice goes
to sleep to confront Freddy Before he can do any more damage to her baby.
She finds herself in the corridors of the asylum
where she's chased but manages to lose him, then
comes out of nowhere and rams him with his giant spiked baby stroller.
(SCREAMS)
I don't know why you would think a baby stroller with these giant metal spikes,
but if I was a baby, this would definitely be my stroller.
It's so metal.
Freddy is tossed down a staircase into the ward for the criminally insane,
and the inmates tear him apart limb from limb.
But none of this seems to even be real, and he appears in another realm,
which is basically an amalgamation of the church, the asylum, the diner and
1428 Elm Street, all jumbled together in a twisted mess of MC Escher physics.
Here, Freddy can be seen trying to befriend Jacob.
He most likely wants to keep Jacob alive and use him the same way that he
tried to use Alice by having him pull others into his dreams to serve up to Freddy.
But when Jacob sees his mom, he realizes something is wrong and runs
for it.
Once he explains that Freddy is hiding out inside her, Alice is basically
able to expel him from her body.
And once Yvonne brings Amanda Krueger's ghost to the scene of the fight, she has some guiding words for Jacob.
-[Amanda] Jacob! Alice will not triumph.
-[Amanda] Only you can help her now.
And he does that by basically turning into a mini Krueger and pretending to
want to learn from Freddy and take his side, I guess.
And then, using the power of the souls that Freddy had been feeding him,
screams and hits him with a blast, pulling the baby Freddy out of his body
as if it had just been piloting this Freddy Krueger mech suit the entire time.
I guess that explains why he was looking so disjointed all summer then.
In the aftermath, we see Alice's love for her child as she absorbs him
back into her body, in contrast with Amanda, who only shows embarrassment
towards her kid as she tries to absorb him.
She warns Alice to just take her baby and leave, and it's not long before
Freddy's arm slashes out from within her.
The last thing we see is Amanda screaming in distress, unable to contain the
evil that she had created.
We never find out if Alice and Jacob managed to escape Springwood or
Freddy's wrath, but we do know that over the next twelve years he came back.
And this time he was totally uncontested.
Taking out large swaths of teenagers as well as kids as young as six or
seven years old.
Some of them turned up in strange places, like the side of a highway, while
others just seemed to go missing.
One by one, Freddy did what he had never been able to do before
with no Nancy Thompson, Kristen Parker or Alice Johnson.
To stop him.
He took out the entire population of kids and teenagers in Springwood, with
just one kid who managed to escape.
The remaining adults in town experienced some kind of mass psychosis,
continuing to operate carnivals, schools and other experiences designed for kids,
while seeming not to notice, or at least not to acknowledge that there
are no kids anyway.
-[Childless Woman] Oh, what beautiful, adorable children would you like to come and live with?
Uh we should burn her alive next.
As I mentioned, there was one survivor, and his name was John Doe.
What's in the box? No, not that John Doe.
No, it's not a placeholder name.
His parents just hate him.
Then again, my parents love me, yet they still named me Zack Morris in the 90s.
And speaking of the 90s, A Nightmare on Elm Street, skips over them.
At the beginning of Freddy's Dead: The Final Nightmare.
A title says the events take place ten years from now.
The movie came out in 1991, meaning that Freddy's next activity would be
set in 2001.
This discarded newspaper says April 22 on it, so let's call it April 2001.
I guess Freddy was trying to tie up loose ends by killing John so he could
enjoy Shrek and Weezer's Green album in peace the following month.
John is taken on a wild dream where he's sucked out of an airplane,
experiences a false awakening and sees Freddy dressed up as a
wizard of Oz witch zooming around his house, which is in free fall.
I guess Freddy's having some fun with this one to celebrate his last
Springwood victim, the house lands at 1427 Elm Street.
The very spot where Krueger took the life of Glen Lance 20 years beforehand.
But John survives and hightails out to a Greyhound station where Krueger
strikes him with a bus, which he also survives. John is break yeeted through a
tear in reality back into the waking world, which has literally never been a
thing before.
When Freddy touches this portal, it closes on him and he says this...
–[Freddy] Now be a good little doggy and go fetch.
Like Alice and Jacob before him, John is being kept alive as part of
Freddy's plan.
This time he's trying to use him to get to his own biological daughter
Katherine, who is now in her 40s and working as a psychiatrist in a
shelter for troubled kids in a neighboring town.
Why he needs John to do this is completely unclear since he is very capable
of leaving the boundaries of Springwood but that is the explanation he gives
-[John ] But you let me live!
–[Freddy] Only long enough for you to bring me back my daughter.
Regardless, as John and Katherine drive back into town to find answers to
the mysteries of their past, three other kids from the shelter stow away
Carlos, Tracy and Spencer.
Although these three are not from Springwood, that would not save them from
the wrath of Freddy Krueger.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
The three runaways end up spending the night at 1428 Elm Street even though
it looks totally different now, where Carlos is the next one to learn why
there aren't any kids in Springwood.
He dreams that Tracy is calling his name and turns a corner to find himself
in some kind of flop house where his mom threatens to clean out his ears
which may or may not be related to the reason that Carlos wears a hearing aid.
The mom reveals herself to be none other than Freddy and sticks a giant
cotton swab through his head.
Somehow this doesn't kill him, so Freddy then throws him through a brick wall
or at least some wallpaper of a brick wall.
How hard would it have been to just make some foam bricks? I don't know.
All I know is that Carlos ends up in the boiler room where Freddy taunts him
for not being able to hear without his hearing aid.
During this era, Freddy seems to spend less time killing and more time
having fun with his victims.
We don't know when his last kill was, but maybe he's just enjoying torturing
this group because he hasn't had a victim in so long.
Also, provided that he's been collecting souls this whole time.
We can assume that he's extremely powerful now, so messing around would
literally only serve for entertainment purposes.
-[Carlos] Give me my hearing back!
So Freddy does just that.
But just like the time he complied with Nancy's request to let her friend go,
his compliance comes with unintended side effects.
Carlos' hearing aid turns into this little parasitic creature and amplifies
the sound way too much to the point that dropping a pin would drive him insane.
Then he threatens to drop a handful of pins, and Carlos screams,
begging him to stop, which makes no sense because of the simple fact that
you can hear your own voice.
And this would be way louder than the pins dropping.
Look, it's been a long video.
My explanation is that this is just dream logic.
After this, Freddy gives him the old nails on the chalkboard routine, and
his head explodes.
Meanwhile, Spencer, the stoner character of the group, falls asleep on the
couch and sees this anti drug PSA on TV.
But Freddy knocks out the host with a frying pan and hypnotizes Spencer into
a psychedelic music video.
We've seen Freddy use a similar tactic before, with Alice getting sucked
into a movie and Mark into a comic book.
I know I've had dreams where I start off watching a show, but then gradually
find that I'm a character in that show.
But strangely, when I tried looking this up to see if it was a common
phenomenon, I couldn't find anyone who shared my experience.
The closest thing I found was people reporting about fictional characters
entering their world, but nothing about the dreamer entering the fictional world.
In Spencer's case, he ends up inside of a video game.
-[Ronnie]  ♪ My life is like a video game. ♪
Thank you, Ronnie.
As he's manipulated by Freddy in the game world, his body mimics those
movements in the real world, leading to him being air yeeted
through a painting.
-[John] I found Spencer.
Oh, my God. Spencer, are you okay?
Do you need to go to the hospital?
Freddy repeatedly stomps on him in the game, then makes him go
full cartoon and basically destroys the house.
At this point, John and Katherine have shown up, and John wants to enter the
dream world to try to save him.
There are so many problems with this, so let's talk about them.
One, John doesn't really even know Spencer.
Two, the reason that characters have been able to enter other
characters' dreams before is because of the special ability passed from
Kristen to Alice to Jacob.
Nobody here is shown to have that ability.
They shouldn't even be able to get into Spencer's dream.
Three, John enters the dream world by asking Tracy to knock him unconscious.
Being unconscious is not the same as being asleep.
You aren't dreaming when you're unconscious.
Your brain is basically shut down.
But ignoring all of that, they discover Freddy enjoying his video game like
a delighted eight year old on Christmas morning.
So Tracy unplugs his controller.
This does very little, though, because in this dream, Freddy's glove doubles
as a Power glove, which, if you don't know what that is, it was a special
controller used for the Nintendo Entertainment System in 1989 that allowed
you to control certain games with hand movements.
Freddy uses it to shut Tracy and John out and take control of Spencer's body,
tossing him down the airs and into a bottomless pit.
Katherine tries to gather Tracy and John and get the hell out of Springwood.
But as John is still asleep in the back of the van, he dreams that he is in
free fall once more.
But Freddy has stowed away in his parachute.
He reveals that Katherine is his daughter and that he only kept John alive
to get to her.
So he cuts him down from the parachute and also comically wheels in a bed of
spikes for him to land on, because I guess just going splat on the ground
wouldn't have been painful enough.
Freddy absorbs his soul, and back at the shelter, nobody remembers the three
boys ever existing, other than Doc, a therapist who works there and
specializes in dream therapy.
-[Doc] He didn't just kill Carlos and the others, he erased them.
I mean, he's never done that before, but sure, add it to the list of rules
that have changed.
Katherine and Tracy are each tormented with dreams of an abusive father, but survive.
In Tracy's case, she tries to fight back with martial arts,
prompting Freddy to say this...
–[Freddy] Kung fu this, b*tch!
Sorry, I just need a minute.
All right, who wrote this line? Michael De Luca.
So after that lady from the carnival, my proposal is that we burn him next.
Alright, I gotta get through this.
So Doc has his own encounter with Freddy and fights him off with a bat,
which is laughable for him at this point.
-[Freddy] In dreams, I am forever.
-[Freddy] Too bad you're not.
Which has the exact same energy as one of the best lines in screenwriting
history from Mortal Kombat: Annihilation
–[Kitana] Mother! You’re alive.
–[Sindel] Too bad you… will die!
Anyway, the Freddy… (laughs) the Freddy.
I'm losing it.
Krueger's making me lose it.
The doctor manages to rip off a piece of Freddy's sweater right before his
alarm goes off and realizes that he brought the fabric out of the dream with him.
This is really important because it gives him the idea to bring Freddy
back out into the real world where he may be mortal, something that nobody
has attempted to do since Jesse and Lisa fought Freddy in the real world in 1986.
So Freddy is vulnerable for the first time in 15 years.
They devise a plan and Katherine goes into the dream with the intention of
bringing the bastard son of a hundred maniacs out with her.
This dream takes her to the Temple of Morpheus, where she passes the dream demons
and symbolically enters Freddy's brain, where she sees all of his
memories and comes to the realization that the Springwood Slasher is none
other than her Springwood father.
And he's not happy about her breaking her promise to keep quiet.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
Katherine and Freddy scuffle, and she does manage to grab onto him, but he
spawns in another room in the real world.
At first, he appears to be human again, no longer sporting the burn scars
and seemingly able to feel pain.
It's never really explained, but I'm guessing this was all just part of the ruse.
Because when he sees Katherine, he tries to convince her that all of
the horrible things he did weren't his fault because of the abuse he
suffered as a kid.
He's trying to play to her sympathetic side because she's worked with so
many troubled kids and felt pity for them.
But what I think he's overlooking is that she was in an abusive household
herself as a child, and she doesn't turn out like Freddy.
She's a functioning member of society.
We talk a lot about the connection between early trauma and, well, villainy
here on this channel, but it's important to remember that going through
stuff in your youth doesn't guarantee anything.
You always have some control in your own destiny.
So Katherine doesn't fall for his bit, whacks him with a nail spiked bat,
and then knocks the finger blade glove off his hand.
She's a switch hitter, and she's got some serious exit velo.
Krueger, who somehow now has his hat back, somehow climbs onto the ceiling.
Does he now have the ability to manipulate things and use his dream
powers in the real world? I have a theory about that, which we'll get to.
Freddy goes in for the kill, bragging that he didn't need the glove to kill
her mother.
She's able to head butt her way free.
Then she repeatedly slashes him in the face with each strike in honor of
someone close to her whose life he had taken.
–[Freddy] Give me the glove! Give me the glove!
You know, for someone who just said that he doesn't need the glove, he sure
seems like he wants the glove.
The fight and possession of the glove goes back and forth, but in the end,
it is Katherine who ends up with it, and he actually encourages her to try
it out for size.
-[Freddy] Go ahead, put it on.
-[Freddy] It's in your blood.
He seems to think that wearing the glove is going to make her evil or
something, but that's not what happens.
She stabs him in the stomach.
Then Tracy tosses her a lit stick of dynamite that they just have, and
Katherine lodges it into him.
–[Katherine] Happy Father’s Day.
His last word is kids before he blows up, finally killing him in the real world,
finally releasing the dream demons within him, and finally putting an
end to the curse of Freddy Krueger that plagued Springwood for the better
part of four decades.
But if Freddy had the ability to use his dream abilities in the real world,
how could he ever really die? My theory is that he didn't.
In fact, I'm not convinced that any of this even happened.
We've seen Freddy use false awakenings to trick someone into thinking
they've woken up, when in fact, they're actually still in the dream world.
It happened to Kristen, Alice and John, so who's to say that it didn't
happen again with Katherine? What if this whole sequence where she wakes up
and kills Freddy in the real world wasn't in the real world at all?
We never see any follow up on any of these characters, so I have to assume
that's what happened.
But even if he came out victorious against Katherine, Tracy and Doc,
He still had a problem.
As stated early in this video, he uses the fear of children and teens to
give him the power to invade dreams.
And Springwood officials seemed to realize this at some point, probably
because there were no kids in the entire town and rumors of Freddy Krueger
invading people's dreams stopped popping up.
Those who had been around long enough could have just made the connection
and figured out how he operates.
And at some point, these survival stories of the few who escaped, like
Dr. Gordon, Alice, Yvonne and possibly Katherine, Tracy and Doc, would have
started to sound more believable.
So the powers that be who came to believe in Freddy Krueger took steps to
ensure that he could never come back and slice through the town again.
Anyone who mentioned Krueger's name would get an unfortunate diagnosis and
be sentenced to treatment at Westin Hill Psychiatric Hospital, where a
steady dose of the Dream suppressant medication, Hypnocil would be administered.
This is the same experimental medication that Nancy used
between 1981 and 1987 to stay off of Freddy's radar.
And it's likely that Dr. Gordon had something to do
with implementing this policy along with Springwood police.
They even went back and scrubbed the public record,
removing and redacting anything about Krueger and his victims.
Eventually, families forgot about Springwood's curse and started moving into
town again, having babies and repopulating the youth.
But this new generation didn't know about the horror that plagued the town
pre millennium, so they weren't afraid.
There were a few hiccups along the way, like Bobby Davis and Mrs. Campbell.
But all of the deaths were staged as accidents or suicides by police.
And anyone heard spouting off rhetoric about Krueger was shipped off
to Western Hills and cut off from contact with the outside world.
As a result, Freddy lost the power to dream crash and for the first time,
found himself stuck on the outside.
Before long, Freddy would make a plea with one of his contemporaries.
Enter Jason Voorhees.
Born in the mid 1900s in Crystal Lake, New Jersey, Jason was nearly
drowned by the other kids one year at summer camp.
He should have been supervised, but the counselors were off having filthy sex.
So just like Freddy, Jason had a disdain for kids and teenagers, and
every now and then he would come back to life and kill some of them.
Jason was defeated by his niece, Jessica Kimball, and dragged down into hell,
leaving his iconic hockey mask behind.
It is then that Freddy reemerges and grabs the mask, hoping to make a
preposition towards the Crystal Lake killer.
After four years of silence, Freddy had a game plan to get back in action.
-[Sheriff Williams] You listen to me.
-[Sheriff Williams] We do things around here a certain way for a reason,
-[Sheriff Williams] and that's given us four years of peace.
Meaning that it was summer of 2005 when Freddy, most likely using the last
reserves of his remaining power, takes the form of Jason's mother,
Pamela Voorhees, and instructs him to wake up and go to Elm Street
to strike fear into the kids now living there.
Jason is immortal and can come back to life as many times as he pleases.
And Freddy's plan is to have him kill and spark concerns in the town that
Freddy has returned, which would give him back some of his power.
-[Freddy] I’ve been away from my children for far too long.
Jason makes the long walk to Springwood, and his first kill is a teenager in
the upstairs bedroom at 1428 Elm Street, which is now restored to more or
less how it's supposed to look.
This prompts some troubling deja vu from two senior officers.
-[Officer] Killed in bed? Jesus. It’s even in the same damn house.
-[Officer] 1428 Elm.
And that's all it takes to get the old Freddy fear train rolling again.
A teen named Lori Campbell overhears the officer s ay Krueger's name, and she
becomes the first person to become vulnerable to him once again.
In her dream, she meets Freddy's last casualty before the fire, a little
girl with empty eye sockets who cautions her that Freddy will soon be strong
enough to come back and suggest that she warns people.
This is obviously Freddy trying to spook her so she can cause hysteria in
the real world and make the town afraid of him again.
That same night, he feels confident enough to make his return and attacks a
boy named Blake using a giant shadow version of himself.
But the slash goes right through him.
Freddy has not yet regained enough of his power to make an impact, so he
sits back and lets Jason do his thing.
After hearing about the new murders, two Westin Hills patients,
Will and Mark,  escape and end up spreading even more hysteria about Freddy.
They think that they're helping prepare people, but in reality,
they're adding to Freddy's power.
Lori's best friend Kia, has a nightmare where he appears in a catalog that
she's flipping through and slices her nose off.
But because he's not back to full strength yet, nothing manifests in the
real world.
But by that evening, the fear powered adrenaline that powered him through
the 80s and 90s pumps through and surges once again.
Freddy is ready to make his comeback.
But there's one thing he didn't take into account.
(IMPACT)
♪ Techno Music ♪
Freddy's next attempt comes that night during a cornfield dance party he
appears to give the girlfriend of Jason's first Springwood victim, taking
the form of her recently deceased boyfriend to lure her to a silo.
Once inside, she finds herself trapped
In Freddy's favorite location, the Boiler Room.
Before killing her, he puts his own twist on a famous quote.
–[Freddy]  The only thing to fear is fear himself.
The original quote, the only thing to fear is fear itself was said by
U.S. President Franklin D. Roosevelt
in his inauguration speech during the Great Depression.
The quote was credited with inspiring many Americans to regain faith in
themselves and pull through the economic downturn.
The last four years for Freddy have been like his own personal Great Depression.
He hasn't haunted the nightmares of any kids, nor has he reaped
any souls.
But now he's pulling through, and the teens of Springwood have something to
fear again.
Yeah, Freddy vs. Jason, deeper than you thought.
Gibb hides in a locker,
But just before Freddy gets her, a wound in her chest bursts open on its own
because Jason, operating from the real world, got there first.
–[Freddy] No! She’s mine! Mine! Mine!
There's also an interesting parallel going on here.
Freddy and Jason's feud begins because Jason moves in on a girl that he
wanted to kill first.
The main character this time Lori, is also caught between two boys.
Tension arises because Charlie had his eyes on her.
But her old boyfriend Will reemerges after escaping Westin Hills,
And he had her first.
Like I said, Freddy vs. Jason.
Deeper than you thought.
Mark, the other Westin Hills escapee, falls asleep at his desk.
And with no hypnocil to suppress his dreams, he drifts off to a scene in his
bathroom where Freddy appears in the mirror, then taunts him,
Using the form of his dead brother. He traps Mark in place, using barbed
tendrils to tie down his feet.
At first, he's willing to keep Mark alive in exchange for sending a message
about Freddy's comeback to the waking world.
But Mark understands his plan and refuses to help Krueger reach more victims.
So Freddy, perhaps realizing that Mark's friends have arrived outside of his window,
decides to send the message himself, lighting the boy on fire and
tossing him around the room in a manner similar to how he once used Tina
Grey to instill fear in that early generation of Elm Street kids.
He finishes Mark with a slash to the face and a message burnt into his flesh.
Freddy's back.
Well, no.
That's Mark's back, technically.
You just inscribed a message on it.
Meanwhile, the Springwood Police Department is already hard at work trying
to contain Freddy Krueger based on what they've learned from past cases, but
not realizing that Jason Voorhees is also on the loose this time.
They quarantine the town, hoping to stop the spread of talk about Freddy.
Meanwhile, Lori Campbell and a group of other survivors are the
first to realize that Freddy and Jason are basically in a turf war now.
Lori dozes off as they're discussing their options and has a
nightmare where Freddy takes the form of her father and tries to kiss her.
Lucky for her, she's woken up by the others just in time.
And even pulls Freddy's ear out of the dream with her.
But Freddy continues to track the group as they head back to Westin Hills.
There, a stoner character named Bill gets a little too sleepy, and Freddy
uses the opportunity to manipulate him in his dream, making him eat this
giant parasite thing, and in the real world, pour all of the hypnocil down
the drain.
Freddy's deductive reasoning skills here are pretty impressive.
I don't believe he can see everything going on in the real world.
If he could, then he would have been able to see Nancy's booby traps.
But when he saw that Bill was at Westin Hills, he made the connection,
figured out their plan and thwarted it.
He also uses this opportunity to get back at Jason, who had shown up to try
to steal another one of his kills.
Freddy takes over Bill's body and sedates him using a tranquilizer known as
Imobitine because every medication in this facility has extremely obvious
naming conventions.
Unfortunately for him, this gives Jason enough time to chop Bill in half
before he can devour the soul.
But from Freddy's point of view, it's probably a worthwhile sacrifice.
He got rid of the hypnocil and pacified his new rival.
Earlier, I mentioned how it didn't make sense for a character to dream while
knocked out cold, but this is different.
It's understood to be possible to dream while sedated, even under anesthesia.
So for the first time, Jason finds himself in the old boiler
room using the appearance of Mrs. Voorhees.
Freddy scolds Jason for not returning back home after killing off a few teens,
then reveals himself as Freddy Krueger and the two icons clash
head to head for the first time.
Being that Freddy can't take damage in the dream world, he's got the home
field advantage in this face off.
– [Freddy]Welcome to my nightmare.
And he also air yeets Jason a bunch of times, which is pretty funny.
Freddy loves air yeeting Jason and really all of their surroundings during
this fight.
We've never really seen him do this before.
It's hard to say if this is a new technique that he's developed or if he's
always been able to do this.
And this time he's just keeping his distance because he knows that Jason
poses more of a threat than the average Springwood final girl.
Whatever the reason may be, the part where he freaking sends Jason across
the room by air humping has gotta be one of the most under appreciated moments of all time.
Like if you type in ‘air humping Freddy’ into YouTube, the only results you get are
Fred Jones and Freddy Fazbear and for some reason Kermit.
But even dropping a water tank on Jason doesn't do him in, which starts to
frustrate his nightmarish opponents.
But it does lead to him discovering Jason's greatest fear, water.
It causes him to revert back to that trembling little boy at Crystal Lake,
and Freddy dives deeper into his subconscious, pun not intended, again, surprisingly.
He's taken back to Jason's childhood the moment the other kids
threw him in the lake.
Lori enters the dream, hoping to bring Krueger out with her, the idea being
that Jason could kill Freddy in the real world and hopefully not come back
to Springwood.
But before she can save young Jason from a watery grave, Freddy emerges and
pulls him under.
Even deeper.
Timing is not on his side, though, and Jason's tranquilizer wears off,
waking him up and vanishing him from the nightmare.
In a rage, he turns his fury to Lori, who tries to pull him out of the dream,
but thanks to another false awakening, finds herself in her own nightmare,
where the truth is revealed about Freddy being the one who killed
her mother.
After taking her out, he comes after Lori, but once again, time is not on
his side, and it would probably help if he just killed his victims as soon
as he got the chance, instead of just hovering over them and talking to them
for two minutes.
But that's not what he does.
The two awake in a flaming cabin in Camp Crystal Lake, with Jason marching
towards them in a rage.
Being in the real world, Jason poses a real threat to Freddy now.
And like the Milwaukee Brewers, anytime they have to play my Cubs,
he's also lost his home field advantage.
Their epic battle tears the cabin apart, but somehow Freddy sneaks away from
the chaos to try to nab Lori and her friends before they can get away.
I like to think that he realizes that he's no match for Jason in the real world
and needs their soul power to buff him up to take on his masked opponent.
However, it's not long until Jason finds him and steals yet
another other one of his victims, and the two duke it out some more.
The fight finds its way to a construction site, where Freddy launches gas
tank torpedoes, releases metal stakes, and manages to get them both struck
by a runaway storage cart.
But Jason is a relentless machine, and Freddy continues to find ways to
fight back.
It probably could have gone on forever, but in the end, Lori and her
boyfriend, Will douse the dock in propane and come back with torches, setting
the dock ablaze and triggering a massive explosion.
Just as he had during his first trip through the real world, Freddy is
torched by Elm Street residents, but this time, it's only briefly.
He falls into the lake, extinguishing the flames, and shortly after comes
for the two surviving teens with Jason's machete.
But with the last of his energy, Jason stabs him through the back with his
own finger bladed arm, giving Lori the opportunity to avenge her fallen
mother and friends with one clean, decapitating slice.
At long last, Nancy Thompson's original goal of killing Freddy in the real
world has been achieved.
But is this truly the end of Freddy Krueger? The evidence would suggest no,
as the last thing we see is Jason emerging from the lake with the
dismembered Freddy head in hand.
But he seems to have the same unrelenting ability to survive in this world
as he did in the nightmarescape of his many victims.
Remember to subscribe to CZ's World for new horrors every week.
Ring the Deathbell for notifications, and I'll see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.
Food. I want food.
So I finished recording the Freddy video.
I think it'll be pretty good.
There were definitely parts that were less fun to talk about than others.
Well, because the fun part is analyzing the characters.
Some of those later sequels.
Not a whole lot of substance to talk about, really.
Honestly. Pretty hard to get through.
Freddy vs. Jason
is surprisingly deep, though.
Yeah, I don't know.
The one problem that I kept running into was the rules are constantly
changing from movie to movie.
It does kind of feel like something's missing, though.
-[News Reporter] Right now.
-[News Reporter] We have some breaking news here this morning, a first on first.
-[News Reporter] The USGS is reporting a
-[News Reporter] Magnitude 4.2 earthquake off the coast of Malibu, California.
There's one more thing.
(IMPACT)
♪ Mysterious Music ♪
I think I figured out why the rules change so much in the Elm Street franchise.
At first I was bothered by this, but I've come to realize the
answer is right there.
It's because a Nightmare on Elm Street, Freddy's Revenge, Dream Warriors,
the Dream Master, The Dream Child, Freddy's Dead and Freddy vs. Jason
Are technically movies within a franchise.
They're just movies made to entertain characters in a movie.
They weren't made to be inspected that closely.
It's not that different from when I inspect newspaper headlines about
Freddy's kidnappings, but the articles themselves talk about baseball scores
-[Announcer] Frederick, Freddy
And Marine corp movements. The real world in this franchise is actually the world
where actors like Heather Langencamp and Robert Englund star in
A Nightmare on Elm Street movies in Hollywood.
Mrs. Langencamp's son even takes a shot at the increasingly unbelievable
logic seen in some of the Elm Street sequels.
-[Dylan] Can you come with me in my dreams?
-[Heather] I think that only happens in the movies.
In terms of the timeline,
This takes place in the modern day of when New Nightmare came out, which is 1994.
After Freddy's Dead, but before Freddy vs. Jason.
-[Reporter] So Heather approaching the 10th anniversary of this whole
-[Reporter] Nightmare on Elm Street thing.
The horror is set in motion when Wes Craven, the director of the original
Nightmare on Elm Street, starts developing an idea for a revival of the franchise.
Even he isn't fully in control of the script, claiming that he
just waits for scary dreams to come to him, and then he writes them down and
incorporates them.
He describes a nightmare entity so ancient that it's existed in many
different forms and cultures.
The only ones that can capture it are storytellers.
It was captured for the last decade in the Nightmare on Elm Street franchise,
but when the series ended, it was set free.
-[Wes] He's sort of gotten used to being Freddy now, and he likes our time and space.
-[Wes] So he has decided to cross over. Out of films into our reality.
After he begins writing, Heather begins receiving ominous phone calls from a
stalker with the Freddy Krueger voice repeating the lines of the in uiverse
nursery rhyme, which weighs heavily on her and freaks out her son Dylan.
She also receives a series of troubling letters burned into book pages in
the mail.
One day, she has a dream that the animatronic Freddy glove, used in a new
Nightmare on Elm Street movie seems to come to life on its own and massacres
the crew members on set before coming for her son.
At first she believes the nightmare was triggered by an earthquake, but
would soon come to suspect a much darker explanation.
During one talk show interview, the host surprises Heather with an
appearance from her Nightmare co star Robert Englund, complete with the
Freddy makeup and costume.
She plays along, but she's clearly pretty uncomfortable because of what
she's going through in her personal life.
She comes home to discover Dylan having an episode, and when she rushes into
his room, he says this...
-[Dylan] Never sleep again. Never sleep again.
Which is the final line from the Freddy Krueger nursery rhyme,
a movie that she had forbidden him from watching.
She also discovers a four fingered slash through one of his toys, causing
her to start to suspect Freddy Krueger may be crossing over into the real world.
Later that night, Dylan expresses a belief that Rex keeps away the
mean old man with the claws.
She insists that there's nothing under his bed, but it's hard to tell if
she's trying to convince him or trying to convince herself.
This is also a reversal of the circumstances from her role as Nancy Thompson
in Nightmare on Elm Street.
In that movie, she believed in Freddy, but had a hard time getting any
support from any parents or authority figures.
Now she's in the position of the parent grappling with whether to believe
her own kid, at risk of giving into the hysteria.
After hearing about Dylan's episode.
His father, Chase, a special effects artist doing pre-production for the
New Nightmare movie, attempts to rush home from the location, but ends up
passing out during the long drive or at least getting drowsy enough to enter
that state of Hypnogogic hallucination the same way that Nancy did as her
body started to shut down near the end of A Nightmare on Elm Street.
Freddy's arm emerges from Chase's seat and
stabs him in the chest, sending him barreling into a wall.
Apparently they didn't show him the same documentary that my class was shown
in film school to warn against the dangers of sleep deprivation.
♪ Who needs sleep! Who needs sleep! ♪
Say what you want about it, but that song was so annoying that it stuck and
nobody ever drove home drowsy.
As it often goes in the movies, Chase's injuries are attributed to
damage caused by the vehicle, as it would be ridiculous to suspect a
supernatural movie character.
During the funeral, an earthquake shakes her husband's coffin loose and she
hits her head in the commotion.
This causes her to have a short dream where Dylan disappears and she finds
him in the burial plot being dragged to hell by Freddy Krueger again.
It probably isn't possible to dream while you're knocked unconscious, but
maybe this time the dream occurred as she was coming back too, because the
head trauma doesn't look as serious.
The night, Dylan seems to be in a trance, standing in front of the TV,
watching A Nightmare on Elm Street.
It appears that he's sleepwalking, and most likely in the midst of a nightmare,
based on his reaction when his mom wakes him up.
When asked where he heard the Freddy nursery rhyme, he claims that he heard
it from under his bed.
-[Dylan] Trying to get up. Trying to get up into our world.
The devil comparison that I made through the first four Elm Street films
that kind of faded away after that is back in a very bold way when it comes
to this version of Freddy Krueger.
Freddy seems to take hold of Dylan again the next day at the playground.
And can I just say, why is climbing on this thing even an option?
Who designed this? And Dylan almost seems to be mimicking what happened to
Philip Anderson from A Nightmare on Elm Street 3: Dream Warriors
the only Elm Street film outside of the original that
Heather Langencamp was in.
It's almost as if Freddy is trying to use her past memories against her.
As they say, the devil's in the details.
Nancy and her costar, John Saxon, are able to run over and catch the boy
before he falls to the same fate that Philip did, but he still seems to be
entranced afterwards.
-[Dylan] God wouldn't take me.
But the devil would. As Heather would find out that night when Freddy's claws
poke through the fabric of her own reality.
But unlike in A Nightmare on Elm Street, this time he really is crossing
over into her own reality.
A loud crash from downstairs wakes her up, but evidence of his intrusion is there,
just as it was in Tina gray's pajamas a decade prior.
Upon investigating the noise downstairs, she finds her son has now fashioned
his own Freddy Krueger glove using kitchen knives, and he attacks her with it.
Thankfully for her, this was also a dream.
The longer Heather stays idle, the closer Freddy gets to the real world.
During one of his mysterious phone calls, his tongue comes through the
phone, just like in Nightmare One.
Heather visits Wes Craven and he tells her that she's a gatekeeper.
The only person who can prevent Freddy from crossing over.
The only way she can do this is by being in the movie.
Only a storyteller can capture his essence.
He may be telling the truth, but the method for stopping Freddy falls
suspiciously in line with his motives as a film director.
It would be like if the brands I work with told me that the only way to save
my family is to promote their audiobook service or meal delivery kits.
Things get even more real when Freddy takes the lives of two more special
effects artists who'd been prepping for the movie, and the animatronic
Freddy glove goes missing.
Eventually, Heather's fears are confirmed.
After being rocked by another big earthquake, she investigates a noise in
her closet.
-[Freddy] Miss me?
(IMPACT)
♪ Haunting Music ♪
Heather's attempted escape from Freddy Krueger results in her being wrestled
onto her bed.
More and more, her scenes as Nancy Thompson in the original movie are coming true.
Freddy even refers to her as Nancy at one point.
Another earthquake shakes her awake, but she isn't unscathed.
She tries to stay with her son as long as possible at the hospital, but
grows exhausted, leading to increasing dreams and hallucinations of Freddy.
Because of this, he continually gets closer to crossing over into the real world.
A Nightmare on Elm Street played with the idea of blurring the line
between dream and reality.
As Nancy became more sleep deprived, she started to experience her nightmare
in the real world.
This mirrored her troubling home situation, where her mother's alcohol abuse
blurred her own lines of reality in a constant limbo between sobriety and drunkenness.
Now Heather has grown up and she's experiencing a new form of
blurred reality.
Losing sight of the line between fiction and the real world,
She increasingly starts to see scenes that she's acted in taking hold in her own life,
like when she goes to find where Dylan is being treated.
– Nurse] Do you have a pass?
–[Nancy] Screw your pass.
–[Hall Monitor] Where’s your pass?
Dylan is moved to a room for special care and sedated.
Although his babysitter tries to keep him awake, he becomes drowsy enough to
see Freddy Krueger appear behind her and gore her in the back.
She's lifted into the air, much like Tina was in A Nightmare on Elm Street,
and Dylan witnesses the horrific murder of his babysitter.
Freddy comes for him next, but Dylan is also a sleepwalker and he's
determined to escape.
The chase, takes him across a busy freeway where a deity like Freddy of the Skies
nearly turns him into roadkill.
Then an entire Krueger army chases him back home.
His mother is relieved to finally catch up with him there, but they're also
visited by a concerned friend, John Saxon, who played Nancy Thompson's dad
in the movie.
He too starts calling her Nancy, seemingly having turned into his character
from the film.
Heather refuses to play along at first, but she continues to see more and
more of the movie coming true before her eyes, until eventually she just
caves in and decides to play Nancy Thompson.
-[Nancy] I love you too, Daddy.
And in any other scenario, calling your co-worker Daddy while off the job
might raise a few eyebrows, even if you are a professional actor.
But this represents Heather playing the character, which is what
Wes Craven told her she would need to do to stop Freddy.
-[Wes] I think the only way to stop him is to make another movie.
-[Wes] Now, I swear to you, I'm going to stay by this computer
-[Wes] And keep writing until I finish the script.
We can assume that this is where he finally reaches and kidnaps the boy,
just as he had in the movies, bringing him to his lair with plans to harvest
his soul there.
Because when Heather returns to the house, which has now transformed into
1428 elm street, Dylan is nowhere to be found, only a trail of sleeping
pills that he refused to take
At the hospital.
She realizes what she must do follow Nancy's footsteps by going into the
dream to face Krueger.
She slides into the world of dreams, where she's spit out of a giant under worldly,
Freddy Krueger shrine that drops her into a deep pit.
She lands in a pool surrounded by Doric columns where there are only two
sources of light the heavenly luminescence shining down from above and the
warm glow of the hellish fires that surround this safe zone.
The scene looks like something mythological somewhere you would expect an
ancient tale of gods and demons to unfold.
Since Freddy's emergence, Dylan has been trying to reach god to protect him
from the devil that is masquerading as Freddy Krueger.
-[Dylan] Why does god let there be bad things?
But when no god came to his rescue, heather had to take things into her own hands and realize that divine role.
Freddy stalks her from just beyond her field of vision, just as Nancy had in
the boiler room in Elm Street.
Her search for Dylan brings her to this sort of greek temple in the underworld,
where she discovers frieses of terrifying looking entities,
perhaps other forms that the dream demon has taken over the years.
At one point, she nearly backs into a giant stone bowl with the word lethe on it.
Referring to lethe, one of the five rivers of the underworld in Greek mythology.
It was believed that when souls died and entered the underworld,
they would drink from the waters of the river lethe to forget
their earthly lives and memories.
This also ties in with the idea of Heather leaving her earthly life behind
to take on the role of a god and find and rescue her son from Freddy Krueger.
Dylan finds her, but then so does Freddy.
He throws her into a pot, which shatters and she's left lying in a shallow
pool of snakes, which he tries to force her head into.
The snakes are also a biblical reference.
The original Nightmare on Elm Street features many examples of characters
trying to turn to christianity to save them, but to no avail.
Christianity holds this concept of the original sin, where Adam and Eve were
instructed not to eat the forbidden fruits, but Eve was tempted by a serpent
who is often interpreted as a representation of the devil.
The idea is to teach that sin is an inherently human trait, so Freddy
pushing her face down into the serpents is meant to make her feel less
divine and more human.
But Heather uses his attack against him, grabbing one of the snakes by its
head and forcing it into his eye.
Nancy is the gatekeeper.
She's not going to be the one to sin, but she'll gladly wait for Freddy to
make a mistake.
She also delivers a pretty solid punch to the face and beats him with a torch.
Torches are another symbolic artifact when it comes to Greek mythology,
often seen as a connection between the mortal world and the gods.
For example, Prometheus was the god of fire who stole fire from the gods of Olympus
and gifted it to humanity.
One tradition that still exists today is the passing of the torch at
competitions such as the Olympics, which symbolizes the continuity of
tradition and the connection between the athletes and the gods,
as the Olympics were considered a sacred event by the Greeks.
But there's also a double meaning here, because Freddy Krueger was burned
alive by the Elm Street parents, some might say torched in the world of the movies,
but even this doesn't prevent him from getting the upper hand in
pinning Heather to a stone tablet with the word Lust written on it.
A surefire callback to the intimate subtext present between Krueger and Nancy
on the screen.
It's part of a greater display of the seven deadly sins, again calling back
to the idea of conflating humanity with sin.
Lucky for her, Dylan comes to the rescue, stabbing Freddy in the leg before
scampering away.
He tosses Heather aside and chases Dylan to this furnace she's knocked out momentarily,
but eventually runs to the sounds of her child's distress,
where she's slowed down by this ground slop on the stairs, just like what
Nancy found herself stuck in on the stairs at the Elm Street house.
Freddy uses his extended arms to reach and grab the boy, then, in a move
that we've never seen in the movies, stretches his mouth open to an
impossible size with the intention of devouring him whole.
A new twist on the concept of consuming his victim's soul.
But with half of Dylan's head engulfed in Freddy's gaping mouth,
Heather arrives and stabs her rival in the back, allowing Dylan to
get loose as Freddy rithes in pain.
This time, Dylan is the one to face imagery of a snake.
Meanwhile, his mother remains vicious with the knife.
She can be seen pulling the blade right out of Freddy's crotch, something
that no amount of pain tolerance can prepare you for, and perhaps the
longtime coming revenge for the years of child abuse and molestation...
In the movies at least.
Even after this, Freddy still manages to recuperate one more time, shooting
out his tongue, which wraps around her head the fifth and final example in
the history of Freddy Krueger's tongue.
It is again Dylan who comes to the rescue, pinning down the devil's tongue
with a knife, allowing the two of them to team up and push him into the fire
once and for all.
As they crank up the flames with this lever, we can see the result of
Dylan's attack on Krueger's tongue.
It gives him a forked tongue, a trait shared with many serpents.
And of course, another attribute commonly associated with the devil.
The devil that took the form of Freddy Krueger to come into our world would
end up sharing the same fate as the character he so closely identified with.
And in his final moments, we can see him transform into his true demonic form.
But we've seen Freddy killed so many times in the dream world, in the movies,
only for him to come back and back and back.
Who's to say that the same won't happen with the true dream demon, the one
rooted in reality? I think there's a clue about his future.
When Heather and Dylan reawaken to the real world and Heather finds the
finished script to the movie that Wes Craven had been writing.
-[Wes] Thanks for having the guts to play Nancy one last time.
-[Wes] At last, Freddy's back where he belongs.
-[Wes] Regards, Wes.
Going off the lore that Wes had provided earlier, which has proven to be accurate.
Capturing Freddy in a story will neutralize him for some time.
-[Wes] Every so often, they imagine a story good enough to sort of catch its essence,
-[Wes] and then for a while, it's held prisoner.
-[Wes] In the story, however it happens, when the story dies, the evil is set free.
And now with no new Nightmare on Elm Street for nearly 30 years.
Are you sure about that? We don't talk about that.
I think it's only a matter of time before the evil is set free once more.
In the original iteration of Freddy Krueger, it was the fear of the children
that kept him alive and in our world, not the New Nightmare world, but in
our real world.
The legacy of these films has kept the fear of Freddy alive for several generations,
and I can only imagine that he'll continue to haunt the
nightmares of many generations more.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new horrors every week.
Ring the Deathbell for all notifications, and I will see you in the next one.
Assuming we both survive.